RIT Green New Deal Cole continues to
push their radical agenda including
trillions of dollars in spending all in
the name of the climate alarmist
religious cult now earlier today Senator
Kennedy grilled Biden's Deputy Energy
Secretary on the plan of the
administration and their excessive
climate spending take a look at this
exchange and how much will that cost
so the cost that I focus on even more is
all the costs now that are going to
happen if we don't cost to get us carbon
neutral how about 50 trillion dollars is
that right it's going to cost trillions
of dollars there's no doubt about it you
don't know do you
deal with reaction host
of the Michelle Tafoya podcast Michelle
Tafoya and
to contributor
[Applause]
we're not talking about billions they're
talking about trillions we have 31
trillion dollars in debt here and I tell
me what the alternative is
well the alternative is this is all dumb
right I mean he couldn't answer the
question because they don't actually
care about the climate it's not about
reducing emissions they don't care about
the issue it's about societal control I
mean aoc's former Chief of Staff gave it
away about the green New Deal he said it
wasn't about the climate it was it was
about trying to change the entire
economy that's the objective here right
they want to do what the world economic
Forum so they want us all to own nothing
shut up and be happy they're trying to
impoverish American citizens and make us
dependent on the government that is the
objective here and then meanwhile
they'll fly around on their fancy
private jets to Davos and laugh at all
of us come on here that's a great point
and we can't eat meat we can't have air
conditioners and uh you're not taking
away my stove I will go to jail for
myself Michelle I will go to jail for
the air conditioning my 92 year old I'll
go to jail for both just say you know
just but here's the deal you know the
amazing part of that testimony was when
Kennedy said to him if we spent all this
money 50 trillion dollars by 2020 or
2050. how much will we lower the
temperature
he could not answer he would not answer
and Kennedy kept saying how much he said
all I can tell you is the cost is
greater if we do nothing that's always
the straw argument I'm not saying we
can't get there and I'm not saying we
shouldn't look toward cleaner energy but
the fact is this plan apparently reduces
the investment in nuclear which is the
cleanest safest energy on the planet all
right we just had Marianne Williamson on
she won't answer the question is Joe in
a cognitive decline why won't she answer
Lisa well
today is too many too many people want
to Pat and Pat back they want to be part
of the crowd they don't want to be
ostracized for speaking the truth and
doing the right thing and unfortunately
she's part of the problem I mean that's
the biggest problem or one of the
biggest problems we face in America
today group think narrative and too many
people want to Pat on the head instead
of doing the right thing everybody sees
it every enemy see it China Russia Iran
they see it North Korea sees it I talked
to people on the left side of the aisle
who see it and believe it
well I know
I I try to be open-hearted but I'll tell
you what they see it they know it and
they say if you love his policies
couldn't you find someone a little
younger and if you don't love his
policies then don't vote that side
Michelle Lisa
hey everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me
and my co-host Harris Faulkner and
Kaylee mcineny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12 p.m Eastern or sets your
DVR also don't forget to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights